un cruce de señalamientos y culpas el
primer debate de candidatos
presidenciales de brasil convocó a los
seis de los doce aspirantes al palacio
de planalto el medio ambiente la
religión la equidad de género y las
políticas públicas me dieron la
conversación entre los políticos pero
los focos se centraron sobre los
favoritos el presidente ya ir bolsonaro
y el ex presidente luiz inácio lula da
silva
su gobierno estuvo marcado por la
cleptocracia un gobierno basado en robos
y este robo fue para ganar apoyo en el
congreso no sólo para el presidente lula
fue para ganar apoyo dentro del congreso
el presidente debe saber que mi gobierno
estuvo marcado por la mayor política de
inclusión social por la mayor generación
de empleos por el mayor aumento del
salario mínimo a pocos metros de
distancia era la primera vez que
intercambiaban ideas en un espacio como
éste es el primer debate televisivo en
el que ambos participan en la historia
por su sabiduría decir nunca se han
visto y siendo un comicio tan polarizado
esto puede tener influencia en el
electorado jair bolsonaro ocupa el
segundo puesto en las encuestas de
intención de votos según el más reciente
informe del instituto de ata folk ya en
las últimas semanas ha reducido la
brecha contra el favorito de 21 a 15
puntos porcentuales pero no podía darse
el lujo de no ir al gran debate como se
rumoraba pues todavía hay un gran
porcentaje de la población al que debe
convencer si el 2 de octubre el día de
las elecciones ninguno de los candidatos
gana más del 50 por ciento de los votos
se realizará una segunda vuelta el 30 de
octubre